why is everyone sending for me
whatever i've done telling me and we can
resolve it why is everyone sending for
me
[Music]
guys welcome back
um cool man you may know the joke about
patreon i'm not gonna
um push that anymore if you don't wanna
if you don't want the juicy juice that's
your business
if you don't wanna sign up for the
juices that's your loss um
new merch i hope you guys are enjoying
let us know what you think obviously
send us over the pics
um i haven't got it on me today but my
instagram already pops a bit so that's
fine
um and yeah
same old same old like the vid leave a
review
subscribe you know the drill um we're
happy to be here
um what fun fact you got today g um
right guys today's fun facts nintendo
the company obviously is sitting on so
much money
that the company can roughly lose 257
million dollars each year and still
survive
until 2017. i'm gonna say that again
nintendo is sitting on so much money the
company can lose roughly 257 million
dollars
each year and still survive until 2017.
that's
50 years 50 years from now well 49 not
including this year
again it's gone yeah
so they they could not so this is them
not making another penny
they could not make another penny no no
they can yeah not make another penny
lose yeah same same yeah okay cool and
lose 250
mil yeah 257 mil for the next 50 years
before they have to go bankrupt that's
ridiculous
wow they're worth i'll just google it
they're worth 1.3
trillion yen to be fair again is
a million i don't think a million is
that much money it is a lot of money
but so what they can you lose that in
dollars or again
no they can lose it in dollars oh wow
but that's they're they're showing on
wikipedia they're showing me their
thingy indiana because obviously the
japanese thing in it
let me actually google the conversion
rate yen to dollars
yeah because i when i'm watching
japanese and they're just like oh
that's that's a thousand yen to them is
nothing so
a thousand yen to be fair a thousand yet
he's only nine
point six dollars ninety dollars like a
tenner yeah yeah yeah
yeah so what's one trillion so trillion
yen would be
like 96 billion 96 900
no no no yeah 960 billion
dollars maybe i don't even know why
bother trying that's too much money
still it's ridiculous
it's more than what's his face
wait what's what's a trillion how many
zeros is it trillion sorry hold on oh my
god
thousand thousand hundred thousand
million
ten million hundred million billion
10 billion 10 billion hundred billion
trillion trillion
jesus jesus that's nine five
oh just press sign again nine
five nine nine five zero zero
ninety 95 million
900 no 95 billion
997 million no 959 billion
959 billion 959 billion
9 million i can't even say the number i
can't say the number but it's a lot of
[ __ ] money
it's a lot of [ __ ] money let's just
put it that way cool man
glad we got that one off our chest jesus
dude that's a ridiculous amount of money
what do you do from here just make more
games and keep the family
right nintendo they're not even
playstation cars yeah but nintendo have
been making
they've got games i don't nintendo i've
got games don't give me one i know a
nintendo are about
it they've been about it mario they own
mario they own mario
nintendo have been about since shortly
like 97 or like 90
or maybe earlier than that because i'm
sure ps1 came out in 1995-ish
and i'm sure they've been back before
when did the n64 come out i'm about to
check now
n64 bro i never had one
it's one of the only consoles i've never
had i've never had
so nintendo itself was founded in 1889.
cool but um i think
hold on for two years older than us
no 1889 not 1989. what did you just say
1889.
yeah nintendo itself i don't think not
like what are they doing
i don't know i don't have the answers to
those questions i actually don't have
the answers to those questions
um nintendo as a company obviously
they obviously weren't making games back
then do you know what i mean yeah yeah
uh let me have a look see
what you asked me for nintendo what n64
yeah when did they jump in n64
nintendo 64 started in release day here
we go
1996. cool so we were five
indian64 came out was that their first
console
i want to say yes cool
i'm asking questions i actually don't
care about best-selling game
super mario 64. 11 million told
calm they may be man
fair play it's a lot of money the ceo
must make cake
the ceo must make cake be stressed
they'll get rid of you like
that with that much money yeah because
they can replace you
no one is irreplaceable when they can
replace you
wow fair play mm-hmm i want
i don't know if i'd ever would you ever
want that kind of money
it's not something i'd ever don't think
i'd ever won or ask for but it's just
one of them ones where i feel like
once you've started making a certain
amount of money you're never to
you're never going to want to drop off
so you're going to try and make more
yeah because if someone said i'm going
to give you 1.3 trillion yen today i'm
like that's
a bit too much i don't need do you need
that much need that much money give me
the point three i'm calm with the point
three that's even way too much money
that's still too much
but yeah that level of money is a lot
that's different money
you can do whatever you want i can slap
your face and there's nothing you can
say to me there's nothing you could say
to me
shut up shut up that's hilarious i can
slap your face as something you can say
to me say to me
oh i'll rock a billionaire if it's jaw
if you slap my face for no reason
i wouldn't need to say anything i'll
rock his jaw off sue me
it was sweet me fam get this flop off
get rid of it it's the hoodie bro i know
it's the windy bro
oh my gaster it's gone now um but
that's crazy i'm thinking like
i'm i'm thinking because they say
in terms of money being a motivator like
a sole motivator
after a hundred thousand a year it stops
being like you saw him over here
who says that studies fun okay studies
show that yeah once you hit a hundred
thousand
pounds a year it's hard for you to be
motivated by money
okay it's hard for you to think i want
this money so i can do this because when
you're making 100
a year even though you're not rich
there's not really that much
anything you can't do you can do
whatever you want 100
a year you can have it will cost you but
you can have whatever car you want
you can have obviously but you just
can't have stupid
stuff like you can't have
um like a brigade that's a two million
pound car yeah
i don't who wants that anyway yeah but
it's like a hundred grand you can't have
a yacht but like who wants a yacht
there's nothing you can't do really out
with a hundred grand so
after that money being your motivator is
slim
slim fair enough and it's like oh maybe
i want to work this hard so i can get
this car
but it's like it's just a car there
really isn't it
yeah i mean yeah it's not really
anything that's like this is gonna
there's nothing that you can do that's
like this is gonna change my life
after a hundred grand this is this
there's no amount of money that's going
to change your life
that's actually achievable like from 100
grand to
10 million yeah yeah that's going to
change your life but like there's not
something you can work towards anymore
you can work towards 100 grand a year
from wherever wherever you are in your
life you can work towards
earning a hundred grand a year actively
and that can be your solomo there
because once you get to 100 grand a year
your life will change forever
but after that there's not really
anything there's no life-changing amount
of money that you can actively work
towards
i'd be like i want that unless you're
yeah
but like you can do it but it's like why
though
i don't need my life to change anymore i
make a hundred grand a year i know what
you mean
why yeah it's mad it's not that much
money
even though it is it is but it's not in
like the grand scheme of money
yeah it's not but i hear what you're
saying i wouldn't
so i always wonder what what people's
motivations are
after a certain point especially if
you're not doing something that you love
very if you're doing something to get
rich yeah and then you get to 100 grand
and you're still doing that thing i
wonder what it is that they're just like
that keeps you going
i don't know i would love to if i ever
make a hundred grand one day
i would probably still i think i'd still
want to keep going
knowing me yeah but you do something you
love
ah if you're making 100
a year as a restaurant manager
yeah you're not gonna be motivated to
get to that 150 grand a year
i know what you mean it's fine yeah i've
made it like yeah
yeah why do i show up every day yeah i
know you can
i can take a sabbatical yeah bro run me
that holiday pete
yeah yeah i hear that so it's a bit
it's just a bit meh you know i mean i
don't know but
um yeah man it's a lot of money it's a
lot of money
i don't know i don't know what people do
with that much money
whatever they want bro it's true
whatever they want it's true
the amount of times like obviously i
work in hospitality people that don't
know
um amount of times i just see people
coming in to restaurants
just because it's a tuesday or just
because it's always because they've got
nothing else to do with their money
fam they've got nothing else to do with
their money it's just bored
i'm getting a chef when i'm rich i'm
getting a chef i've said it so many
times i would sacrifice my quality of
life so i can have a chef i know i know
exactly because i'm
sometimes i just can't but not even the
fact that i can't be bothered to cook
sometimes there are things i want to eat
that i have i don't know how to cook one
two i'm not researching it and trying to
figure out recipes and [ __ ]
up and three i just can't order a take i
want it to be done in my yard
i want to smell it yeah man i know i
want to eat i want to tell dunny fam for
the next
eight weeks oh eat healthy yeah but i
want it to taste good
and he will whip it up he or she would
whip it up
whipped done and i'm eating all the time
thinking this can't be healthy
and i'm shredded
this is too easy oh if i had underground
i'd be shredded
because i'm not working i'm not going to
work you can't force me to go to work
anymore when we make a hundred grand on
this part
i'm doing it with my top off i'm
shredded that from
from then onwards i'm shredded all right
shredded
i'm just training and eating and
laughing that's all i need to do now
i made it amazing
i want to be shredded now fam i'm a mess
let's just address this to today i am
just a mess
i am a lot better than i was the last
lockdown
last lockdown i was a mess because i
remember looking back at
there was a time where i watched our
videos again and i remember looking at
because i watched them i don't listen to
them so i remember looking at
the lockdown videos like protein videos
and i saw my face i'm thinking
bro you put on weight because this was
when lockdown had ended and yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i was looking back and thinking bro you
put on weight because
you probably not like me oh my no you're
not talking about me yeah i was gonna
say
you think i'm just gonna sit there oh
lodge a cat in your head
oh god oh god i said the lord should cut
in your head
i did though
sat down for the whole day and i was
like what is this aching
pain what's this sting in my pet in my
in my [ __ ]
guard fam i lifted up my top and the
belt buckle was
digging into my fat stomach so hard that
i left it in dead and it was red raw
and i was like i looked in i looked at
god and i was just like
that's not the one you told me oh what
did i tell you what you told me was
when you were sitting down you had a
plate of food and you're stubborn
fam i forgot about that one
i remember that monkey's stomach pushed
the chicken
sat down and went like that and then the
chicken
i was so angry look to my left and right
see if anyone saw that
oh i'll be so guided with life
i'm so gutted i was fed up and that was
that was definitely when the gyms
weren't open
and i was just like what am i gonna do
i tried everything i tried running i
tried went to the park i did pull ups in
the park i was doing press-ups at home
had my little dumbbells i was just
curling squatting everything nothing
worked
nothing worked i was sick of it i needed
the gym to open two of the gyms open i
hit hard
i was looking good for a few remember
yeah and then they closed again
and i'm exactly when the second lockdown
happened i decided on the spot i'm not
doing anything
i'm just going to get fat and i'm just
going to have to deal with it yeah i've
been a lot more comfortable with my
fatness this time around
um but obviously this one's only like a
month per month so it's fine but um
oh yeah in the first one i was a mess
i'm i'm a mess again now but i'm not as
bad as
the first one i was depressed and i was
skinny
i was skinny and fat um yeah skinny
chubby scat
over just pure scatty was a scat that
was a flipping mess
man my arms were skinny but my stomach
was fat i used to sit i used to stare at
myself in the mirror and say who would
want to [ __ ] this
what woman in their right mind would
want to [ __ ] this no
you look at yourself like i'm horrendous
i'm absolutely horrendous
because females there's with your hair
if your hair grows your hair grows and
it's calm that's what they want that's
what they want like it's fine for you
guys but if our hair grows no trim no
shape up
our body's looking a bit aggie it's just
like oh you stop pull yourself together
that's it bro pull yourself together
that's the speaking of gyms
these men you men are [ __ ] in the
comments
the barbers were closed i couldn't get a
trim
i couldn't get a trim and these are like
oh james get
a twin for [ __ ] just get a trim how
how what do you expect from us we're on
a
that's illegal we're at a tight leash
here oh fam
i needed it you think i i wasn't
self-conscious enough to see the youtube
comments like ah
get a trim oh man said that quarren trim
is looking
tough leave me alone i read that
i said i read that i read that man i
could do about it i get abused on this
there's nothing i could do about it
i think i want my dragon with pride that
day
bro oh my days fam yeah the
the whole thing is when your hair's long
your gut's fat your arms are skinny
it's not a good look and your pecs kind
of just drool
they just my pets after the first
i felt quarantine an old man insane gee
like round here was saggy my nipples
were saggy
nipples touching the nips bro touch me
on the nips
my nips were just in turn just droopy
it's just like family you know i mean
like
when they get cross-eyed
[Laughter]
shake it off
is standing in my boxes just like what's
what is this
oh and you've got the love handles over
the side of the box you know when your
waist is
bigger than your hips and you're just
like like a mess
and your legs are slim as well you just
look like a
oh my days you look like an upside down
bars fram
i look like i work in finance
i was vegs oh i was vegs
ah as soon as the gyms opened i was like
never again
bro i scroll through my instagram i
think this is what i used to look like
oh
i was a specimen now i'm a joke
but hey ho um we should set something
do you want to set like a challenger
sign okay let's get shredded
so abs you have to have an app okay so
i'm not saying we have to get diced yeah
but we have to have at least
a visible abs somewhere on your stomach
yeah by what
feb by your birthday bet
bet because i wanted that anyway because
i'm going to need to buy so bet you're
going to be in dubai on your birthday
not
not even by choice my friends my
friend's wedding i was going to say
but i was about to say raw yeah third
even to fight
no invite not even a mention
i was waiting for that wow
it's not my choice it's not my choice my
friends get married over there she lives
out there all right come come come on
my birthday is for that my guy's my
birthday's on the 17th of feb if you
want to send me a little
satin um uh yeah i'm going to be in the
buyer on the 16th
from the 16th from the 15th for saying
so oh so inevitably going to spend my
birthday
in dubai oh that's dead fam yeah i've
never missed your birthday
i said that one time that was a good
birthday i know it was as well that was
good
that's the only one of your birthdays
i've ever missed i was live i've been
delivered about the birthday i know
i got sweated i know you did i'm so
annoyed because i'm tired of those
[ __ ] everywhere
i'm so annoyed i missed that birthday oh
it was a good day um
cool man i don't know what i'm jumping
out of a plane for my video for you
coming of course
you're gonna do this yeah gang i've got
no choice we spoke about this on the pod
like
20 minutes yeah we did we did we did we
did i'm scared
do you think i'm not these man you're
getting my favorite
life when i see you with the goggles on
i'm gonna lie i know you will i know you
all that's the thing i know
you i don't even know why i just know
you you've got to point and laugh
you're faced with the goggles and the
skull cap and you just fix
i sit on next man's lap
[Laughter]
hopefully somewhere warm all right but
hopefully somewhere warm
but um i really don't know april
2021 leaping out of the plane that's
petrified
oh it's terrifying but i said i used to
say it when i was a kid i used to say
all the time
i'm going to do it and i used to beg my
mom let me do it and she was like are
you stupid
you're a child you can't jump out of a
plane yeah and i was like cool i
remember asking my mom i was literally
sitting in a car remember where i was
and i was like mom how old do i have to
be to jump out of a plane then
to do a skydive how would have to be and
she was like 18
and i was like better i don't know 18
then 18 came and went
1800 james is just vexed in 12 years
i'm like i should probably do it i've
been chatting the most
what you're gonna have to do now
everyone's gonna hear everyone knows now
so yeah i'm gonna do it
on my 30th leap out so um yeah man that
should be fun
i'm kind of scared about turning 30. you
are scared about today
yeah i feel like i am as well i feel
like it's it's a huge turning point in
what the thing is
i feel like society makes it a huge
turning point yeah i know you mean
because when when you hit 30 and you're
single and you've
like you've got no uh what's the word
i'm looking for like you're not in
private you know malaysia's ship and
you've got you've got me not i've got a
house
you've not got these they've been [ __ ]
together you haven't got your [ __ ]
together basically
yeah basically man's not active you know
i mean i'm not doing what i need
you haven't got your [ __ ] together it's
a bit like but i also
love it my life yeah man but it all
depends on that's the thing as well you
love your life and for one
obviously i can't speak in the
relationship i don't really think if
you're if you're single in your thoughts
that just means nothing to me and it
means nothing to me but yeah
especially females yeah that's more of a
body clock team you think
we spoke about it before we think anyway
but um yeah for me yeah it's like
if you i've always thought fine if i
didn't have my [ __ ] together 1 30
like doesn't help that when did we start
this how old was i 28
yes yeah when we started this i was 28
yeah we were 20 years old
yes yes yes yeah yeah so it's like
if you start something start the thing
you wanted to start when you're 28
by 10 30 you're not gonna have your [ __ ]
together but that's that's all right
because if you started when you're 18 by
30 you had [ __ ] to give a long time
of course so it's like it's more about
when you
started the journey and there's no real
there's no real timeline on them
but yeah i do know what you mean you
turn 30 you feel like you have good [ __ ]
together you're just like
yeah it's more about the questions i
don't care personally
when people ask me it just drives me
insane but anyways i think you spoke
about
on bella's on bella's episode oh yeah we
did yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's tough man being that
is long as well man it's like
you're actually grown 20 something
i feel old as 29 but at least i'm 20
something yeah yeah
30. someone asked you how old are you
30. there's no coming back about that
that's a statement yeah 31 and 39 are
literally the same thing
do you know what i mean until you're 40.
yeah 21 and 29
are miles apart miles apart you're
different people like 21 and 29
30 and 39 same thing same thing
oh god terrifying
terrifying i'm looking forward to
looking back though like you said before
i'm intrigued to know what i'm going to
be like in 10 years and where i'll be
when i'm 30 90
yeah 140. i'm turning 40 i'm going to be
i'm going to be caked
crispy cakes with a salt and pepper
beard oh
i'm i'm certain when the grey comes in
i'm going to be yeah salt and pepper
pepper prickled
and i'm just going to be sexy i'm going
to be the penguin alive for the sideburd
i think i'll be picking up but that's
fine i
you will be paying also but that being
said i
actually don't think strange people ate
that well you know okay i have a feeling
i'm trying to think of mixed race people
that like you see get older and think oh
he's still got it
maybe lenny kravitz and that's it is he
even mixed race i was about to say i
don't even know if he's mixed race not
that i know he is but i don't know if he
is
he's probably not i'm the cooker i don't
please say is
please say let it grab his mum's right
lenny kravitz
relatives his mother roxy rocker his
mom's
dark fam oh um it doesn't show his pops
oh dear what's his pop's name does it
say it doesn't even say
sugar so who knows oh no
someone please let us know if we know me
lenny
oh crevice but yeah i don't think mixed
people age that well
i don't think that it's bad but like not
as well as black people
black people not all black people age
old but yeah obviously not all black
people
but yeah a lot about people's age just
fine
my parents don't look like their age at
all my dad looks
the same it's weird my dad looks the
same as one of those apart from a few
gray hairs
he looks the same as when i as when i
was yeah same
it's so weird like my dad sent me a
picture of
um him a little while ago when he was
17.
he looks the same just with hair
and i was like that's crazy you look the
same
um so hopefully i'm gonna be banging
when i'm in my 40s
i hope so i hope i will be um
i just have to keep if i keep my diet
right i'll be all right
chef if i have a chef it's a long fiber
chef oh yeah it's perfect
it's perfect i'll wake up with a green
drink
some vitamins some porridge blueberries
fresh honey no blueberries for me
antioxidants make me sick
antioxidants make me sick antioxidants
make me sick fam you need to see a
doctor
that doesn't even make sense oh like you
know it's just that that sensation it
gives me here
like you know when you bite into like a
blueberry or like a raspberry it gives
you that
like that tart feeling no you don't like
it no i like a bit of that it drives me
mad that
dries a little bit of that with that's
where you balance it with the sweet
little bit honey on top that
balances it out um i've got phone case
by the way
it actually resonates seeing as we're
just talking rubbish
so you're saying he's talking rubbish
too no he's asking about us talking
rubbish
okay man said can you talk about how the
podcast's
name came about and does it get hard to
talk
when you're tired or hard to know what
to talk about sometimes
thanks guys funniest pod out there
um well you came up with the name shits
and games well you write it by me i was
like gang
oh yeah i was actually stressing about
it for ages i was trying to think of a
name for ages but actually it's funny
um i'll say that cheers was actually
probably the first name that came to my
head
and then i was like nah and then i
thought i'll probably think of a better
name
and then i just went for a million
millionaires ask people for
suggestions and i hated every single
suggestion that was given to me what
session did you get do you remember i
can't remember fam
i literally can't remember but i was
just like nah
nah nah nah and i also didn't want uh
to sound like anything else okay a lot
of people like to name like
shows or podcasts and stuff like off
other famous stuff
okay like i saw one the other day that
was called like the ho rogers two yaps i
got the ho rogan podcast
oh and i was like why would you call it
that
like why would you call it that you've
just put a ceiling on yourself straight
away yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um so yeah like um
would you call it i think she's good
with the first one i fought off and i
was just like
listen man if he's the first one i got
bored after a while because i don't want
to think about this anymore
it needs to be easy let's just do it it
was a great name
as soon as you said it to me i was like
yeah boom right no no hesitation
gang so yeah that's yeah the name's an
easy one it was the i don't know how it
came to me it's the first one that came
to my head and i'm just like cool and
then
i'd liked it so we went with it um
in terms of to talk about is it hard to
do when we're tired
yes but no because it does it doesn't i
don't in my opinion so
it might be my in my opinion it's not
harder to do when you're tired
it just brings a different vibe when
you're tired yeah like i'm tired right
now
yeah last episode i wasn't tired i'm
tired now um
but it doesn't mean that it's hard to do
yeah it's just
i'm not jumping around so i mean i'm
just it's more relaxed conversation
which has its merits um so in my opinion
i don't think it's harder to do when i'm
tired but before we
record when i'm tired i've said a
million times before we record when the
camera goes on i think
this is going to be impossible this is
going to be
i know i know what you mean i don't know
how this is going to do
how can we be this many episodes and
this is and
because i feel like this all the time
when we've done because we've done
sessions people that don't know
we've done bulk sessions around about
when quarantine first died and we didn't
know when we were going to see each
other
we did one session of recording where we
had to record
10 or 11 episodes in one sitting so um
yeah for people that don't know yet we
um during quarantine the first
first ever quarantine in the uk um i
mean if i didn't know when we were going
to be able to see each other so
i made one scary illegal trip
up to manchester tried to stay off all
the main roads because police were
moving hot
i'm even mad they were moving pulling
people over left right and center
so i managed to make it up here and then
so we had one night i think arrived
probably about
midday uh so we had midday until
i think probably midday the next day the
next day yeah and we just recorded like
11 episodes
and i was distraught
some of them in there yeah i don't know
how people thought it was any good
but when when you listen to them back
listen to a watch them back i was like
oh that's all right
but i remember how i felt when we were
recording that one yeah when it was like
the 9 10 and 11. i think i don't want to
do this anymore bro this is awful
yeah that was bad it was a bad time but
here's what it is man like
when i'm tired i feel like before we got
the studio
it was always harder for me to record
obviously before the camera switched on
and everything we always used to be our
[ __ ] hour tire tire tired
we'd procrastinate like crazy when we
did it at your house isn't it
procrastinating we used to procrastinate
like crazy days for ages yeah
for ages but having the studio now i
feel like even though even though i am
like
jimmy said i'm tired now as well but
it's a different atmosphere when i come
here
i feel like okay it's a new environment
new surroundings
once the camera switches on we just go
yeah once i sit in this chair i'm like
cool we're ready to go yeah yeah i did
nothing i don't think about anything
else but yeah
we used to procrastinate like crazy how
we got anything done
it used to just to take just the setup
yeah we'll take like over an hour start
up alone we'll take god because we'll
just be
talking or oh i'm hungry i'm just gonna
grab a drink i'm just gonna go toilet
i'm just gonna do this before we start
and everything like that
and then we'd finally sit down and get
something done how i don't know
how i don't know we were so unproductive
yeah it would take ages to get something
done
it would ah what we're pathetic we are
pathetic
now it's a lot better it was so it's a
lot better so i hope you guys are
seeing the difference anyway yeah yeah
yeah but yeah there's definitely times
in there where i thought like
this this is complete trash there are
times i've thought that and i've watched
or listened tonight i've never been to
i've watched it back and i think
it was such a good episode it was
actually really good absolutely yeah i
remember the one that always sticks out
for me
was the one the time i asked you about
the carly jenner thing
like what would you do because that was
me
clutching at straws my mind was fried i
was thinking
me going back to l.a blah blah blah
you're going back and forth to l.a about
all this stuff
whilst we were recording that i was
thinking this is garbage
who cares the fans loved it it was a
great one i listened to it back and i
was intrigued
and the fans loved it i was like because
i it was so weird because i was dreading
that one coming out
because when we were recording it that
was literally i think that was out of
the eleven that recorded that was either
nine or ten
and i remember i specifically remember
thinking this is
trash what am i on about
what am i even talking about like who
cares this is something that's never
gonna happen and
whatever like i'm just asking for ex
random questions
and then yeah once it once i listened to
it back i was like that's true right
it's not bad that's actually all right
it's not that's not that bad at all so
when your team likes you just don't you
think about oh i'm just chatting but
yeah when you're tired you think you're
just out i felt like we had nothing left
to talk about
and yeah sorry his final question was do
we ever
struggle to find things to talk about um
i'll let you go first announcer
oh you could go first i was going to say
i feel like obviously when we first
started this show or the podcast
it was kind of like a free-for-all we
were just
implementing ideas as and when and going
with the flow and blah blah blah
so i don't know if you would realize but
in our earlier episodes
we were just talking we were just
absolutely talking for as long as we
could
and then try and find a story here there
and everywhere but as you know now if
you are a seasoned listener or viewer
it's more of a structured show now we've
got elements and implementations of how
to structure the show and
this happens here and this happens there
and blah blah blah so you've got that
also we've got the fun facts fan
requests just chat [ __ ] in between you
know i mean
now it's more it's a lot easier to
understand and navigate how the show is
going to work and how the show is going
to
pattern itself out whereas before we
were just talking i'm just talking we
were just talking and then slowly but
surely idea started to come into place
and that's the best way
that's the only way yeah we would have
been able to do it anyway yeah yeah i
don't think we would have had to i don't
think
bef on episode one we're like okay we're
gonna do this this this this we just
spoke
yeah yeah that's the best way to yeah it
was cool man and it developed in its own
way
exactly um but yeah like
um there's not really been that many
occasions where i've actually thought i
don't know what we're going to talk
about there's been times on there where
i've
only had like one thing
that we can talk about and i'm like bro
i don't know how this is going to go
because this could last 30 seconds and
then we'd bring it up and it would last
like an
hour yep i'll just talk about one thing
and i think wow
that's the beauty of it that's the
beauty of it you just never know what
one thing
could lead to all the tangents we go and
we go on obviously you guys know we go
on tangents galore oh and it's just the
best way to navigate a conversation yeah
yeah we never struggled we talked about
this yesterday wasn't it we never
struggled with things to talk about a
lot of
the thing is a lot of people that meet
me that are new and i tell them i do a
podcast
um they always ask me oh how do you know
what to talk about and blah blah blah
it's just just the way it happens i
always tell them same thing because it
was more of a structured show now yeah
yeah i think as well yeah like um i
remember when we started
this was what this was really
really early must've been october time's
done uh around yeah so this was
after the first so i think i came to you
for the first two trips i think we
recorded in the first ever trip i came
out to do it we only recorded two
episodes yeah i remember
and then i think i came up again and we
may have recorded two
or three
yes because you had your boy in between
because you had to record with him down
south
yeah i did a couple with with john i
didn't want my brother
yeah yeah so yeah i think i i came up
again we did two or three
and then on the third trip you came to
mind we did a couple of mine
and i remember when we were at mine we
were asking
we had no instagram followers or
anything oh yeah we had like 20s
maybe 30 40 50. and then we were putting
out on the stories like yo give us some
topics give us some
topics like anything i think maybe we've
got one person say one thing
and i was like bro this is helped me to
help you yeah
it's hard out here now i've
my notes from people's messages and
stuff like that
is filled flooded and the ones that we
haven't read
is filled and i'm like oh my god
we've got more than we than we could
ever use i've ever bargained for we've
got too much
yeah so which is such a great it's a
great yeah it's awesome so please guys
if you ever send us something and we
don't ever end up speaking about it
don't
please don't be angry because yeah we
get so many there's so many
which is awesome but yeah we can't get
through all of them we've just kind of
there's not enough episodes in the world
um but yeah man like so that makes it
definitely easier in terms of like
things to not talk about because like
there's been times where i've thought
like the way the way my structure works
is a nice little insight like
the most topics i get that i'd like to
talk to foo head about
is usually when i'm just driving in the
car and then i'll just
something will randomly come to my head
and i'll start laughing about it and i'm
like that's topic
and then i'll write in my phone but
times where i feel like there's been
times where i've come up here
i feel like i've got 100 topics i'll
look and i'll be like
oh we've actually spoken about that oh
we've spoken about that oh we've spoken
about that and i'll delete delete delete
all the ones we've spoken about and i've
got nothing left
and then i'm like [ __ ] i ain't got
nothing to talk about
and then um i'll say oh we've got a fan
request let's talk about this
i think that will go go go go go the
whole thing
and for that it's the whole thing and
sometimes there's been times where i've
really had nothing to talk about and
we've done like two fan requests
because it's like i've got nothing and
then someone might send in oh would you
rather then just do that
and it's just nice it's so nice so thank
you guys you guys
seriously help us out because yeah
sometimes we don't have a lot to talk
about but there's been times where
that's okay as well because
that's what to do with you really it's
just you're easy to talk to
um i couldn't talk about that with
anyone um true i hear you
um and there's something different about
um i'm saying this when we first
kind of when we really first started it
was like um there's something very
unique about being in a situation
like recording poker is one of the few
times in my life i think within anyone's
life
where you're actually having a
conversation for the sake of having a
conversation
your only intention is to have this
conversation true usually when you're
having a conversation
you're you're in the midst of something
else you very rarely sit with someone
and say we are going to talk we're just
going to talk
and it doesn't matter how long we're
here we're just going to talk
and there's your mind works in a
different way when you're not scared
to go down a rabbit hole in something
else yeah because usually like
the best conversations you usually have
with someone like oh when we're on the
plane going here
they're all situations where you have no
choice but to bore in the car
you have no choice but to be in the
place that you you'll be in yeah but
even that has a time limit yeah
because we're only going to be the plane
for so long we're only going to be in
the car for so long i've also gotta pay
attention to the directions i've gotta
do this i've gotta focus on all these
other things other stuff is happening
but when you're in here we're in this
closed locked room there's just us here
there's no time limit it's just like we
can be here as long as we need to be
here
and it helps it really helps like your
mind think actually like
digest the stuff that other person is
saying to you you actually like i hear
you a lot
better when you're saying stuff here and
it allows me to kind of come back
with something a little bit more fluid
okay that you can continue with
because i'm actually actively listening
to what you're saying that makes sense
and i'm picturing what you're saying as
well it's loads of senses whereas if i'm
on my phone like texting and you're
saying something
you're not i'll give you an answer but
i'll be like yeah yeah cool there's no
real investment
yeah i don't you need to keep this
conversation going because i've got
other stuff going on i've got [ __ ] i've
got [ __ ] there's tv on this
this phone is this and everyone was like
whatever bruh
um so yeah once you're in here it's easy
to talk
yeah especially if a lot of people
um have dm dust
or dm to me i don't know if they have
dms used um separately and said oh
uh you love your podcast etc so
obviously thank you for that and they
say that they want to start a
podcast and blah blah blah and they say
that obviously their first question is
like how do you start like how do you
know what to talk about blah blah i said
my first response was it's all about the
chemistry you have with that person
as long as you know you can comfortably
talk with that person regardless your
podcast will bank
yeah as long as you can have a good
conversation with the other person in
the room
it doesn't matter what you talk about
yeah the conversation yeah the
conversation just has to be the
conversation you would have
with that person if the cameras were off
yeah and that's it and i've
intentionally never
you have to like you can always tell
when you watch something especially if
it's like a new show or a new podcast or
something
you can always tell by how the person's
speaking
if they if the other person they're
speaking to you already knows what
you're what you're on about
so if i've so we would say if we want to
drive over here and i told you a story
and then you were like oh you should
have said that for the podcast that's a
dope story
and then i was like i'll just say on the
podcast anyway
it you people can just tell that it's
not genuine
yeah your reaction's not genuine the way
i'm saying it is not genuine yeah it's
more
planned it's all scripted and it's all
planned and you're reacting and you
some somehow you just know that's what's
going on yeah and it just doesn't sit
right
and then that's when the conversation is
dead
so like when we first started this i
would intentionally not tell you things
yeah just so i could tell you what here
yeah yeah but then after a while that
started to annoy me
because then we were never having any
conversations that weren't in this room
and i was just like
you're also my best friend i still want
to talk to you
then i just started locking that off and
i'm just saying things anyway yeah yeah
yeah but now i just have to be
okay because we were having a
conversation last night over dinner i
kind of remember what we were talking
about
but we were having conversations last
night over dinner that i remember saying
last night oh this would be sick on the
pot
but i have to i have to be okay with the
fact that that's done now we can't talk
about it again because it's done yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've had those i know
exactly what you mean
yeah i know exactly what you mean guys
also
get us on gogglebox 100 oh go go get us
on goggles oh yeah yeah yeah we'd ride
for global box we were we were watching
david outbreak we're watching a lot of
david
we were going off and we were going with
the commentary was a one
it was a one it was live it was
live oh that was intense it was intense
even the ones i've seen like the line
one with the hyenas i've seen that
i was there i was scared when man was
dribbling up the things tired
his eyes were sunk in when his boy came
when his brother came
and he dropped to the floor i've never
laughed so much in my life
bro he dropped he flopped thank you lord
thank you
i was done i'm tired i've never laughed
so much in my life
yeah goggle box below how do they on
google box i don't actually think they
make that much money
it's not even about the money but of
course no i'm saying but you make
actually i think you make a right oh i
think you make like i think you make
like 1500 a month
that's not bad no it's not just like a
standard wage that's not bad at all but
i'm just saying that entertainment value
will be
through the roof oh 100 bucks through
the roof i promise
yeah i think we're back on goku box has
to be late night one though
because we swear oh yeah we swear yeah
you've got something else i was trying
to see if i've got one which i'll
probably do but i'd have to find it i've
got it
you've got one hit me up cool man this
one you'd like this one
what do you mean about me
what do you mean elaborate what do you
mean it's about me i'll tell you if i'm
gonna be the dream i'm answering peace
you can't just say that i can i did it
on purpose
i know you did
not talk to me okay all right monster
drunk good
so this guy am i the [ __ ] for taking
had's advice
does that unless you decide yeah i'm not
joking
wow right
okay so a while back i messaged you man
needing advice
because i was low on confidence and in a
bad place at the time both of you gave
me very good
i think good advice but it was foo heads
that i really took into consideration
and actually were actually worked on
so like foo has suggested i worked on
myself i went to the gym
i remember the specifics i overhauled my
wardrobe completely got a haircut
and just all around became the best
version of myself so this time ago
yeah i'm really sorry you did send this
age as well yeah because i'm thinking
this is time ago yeah you said it ages
ago bro like this is what i mean
you've got so many i'm just trying to i
intentionally tried to
like not just put the newest ones at the
top yeah because then we'll never get
through the old ones
but yeah this is how we end up like a
timer yeah
um
became the best version of myself yeah i
now had a bucket load of confidence
and was comfortable in my own skin going
yeah indeed gang i could quite frankly
pull anything without fearing rejection
one bit
yeah bro so massive thank you for you
had
he said thank you my god that means fine
i'm sure my advice was perfectly
adequate but whatever
i'm not bitter it's all good um now
there was a thing i was chatting to at
the time
prior to the transformation i never
really made my intentions clear but it
must have been obvious to her that i
liked her she also never
showed any interest in man fast forward
post-transformation i stopped talking to
her and just completely cut her off
going i then started chatting to another
team who apparently was her best friend
but i didn't know that at the time okay
we talked
for a bit but i wasn't really feeling
her in that way so i just hit it and
moved on
gang i then started messaging these two
other things
hit those walls as well and moved on
he's moving crazy he's moving he's
taking my advice and left with it
he wow okay little did i know that all
of these yaps were besties
now the issue came about when i somehow
got brought up into the conversation and
they realized that i'd slept with the
whole squad
except the one yet that i'd originally
liked
sedyat then proceeds to message me
saying i've made a mug of all her
friends
cussed me out and [ __ ] saying that she
really liked me even though she never
showed an ounce of interest i brushed it
off and moved on
until we all just randomly met at a
party
all of them proceeded to gang up on me
calling me out calling me a fat boy
swearing at me the works
obviously i didn't let it faze me but
that whole issue really made me
contemplate on whether i'm a bad person
or not i quite frankly
don't think i'm a fuckboy even when i
inadvertently slept with the whole squad
borrowing that one yet i made myself
very clear
that it was strictly sex but clearly i
hurt these guts
and i would want to do that i wouldn't
want to do that
i like the person i am now and don't
want to change it for [ __ ]
so am i the [ __ ] for taking through
hud's advice
um considering it was my advice i don't
think you're an answer for taking my
advice
it just depends on how you implement the
advice i give you
those are two completely different
things um so me telling you to
um work with what you've got obviously
take yourself to the gym boost work on
your confidence boost your self-esteem
you took that advice and i'm happy for
you but you ran with it
i was like after the first night you
were just knighted which i'm proud
i'm proud of you oh yeah i'm not judging
that's gang
obviously it's it's sticky when you're
banging four out of the five girls in
the same click
and i don't i find that hard to believe
that
none of them knew they had [ __ ] you
what's going on i found that very hard
to believe
because if you're
let's say you've banged two chicks out
of five from the squad and you've tried
to bag the thirteen
unbeknown to knowing that they're in the
same squad you've not just got her
number
you're searching on instagram you are
everyone is yeah and you're going to see
the mutual friends you're going to see
so i find it hard to believe there's no
pictures of no one nothing i find it so
they're all best friends best friends
someone's lying somewhere do you know
what i mean someone's like lying
somewhere
i'm not saying it's you and i'm not
saying it's them someone's lying
fam every single time someone sends us a
message
there's always holes that someone's
trying to keep from us and we always
figure out
they're not stupid yeah bro there must
have been a picture of someone
in this group girls don't just all have
pictures of themselves nothing
no highlights nothing no story even the
in the the one next to it which one tags
the one you're tagged the stuff you're
tagged in
no comments in the pictures big man come
on
come on you're playing a little bit dumb
yeah you're playing my evil i feel like
yes you're not an answer for taking my
advice you're an answer for not
using an initiative or common sense oh
yeah yeah because
yeah there it like i said there is no
way you're not you need to do your due
diligence before you
even want to patent anything you have to
do
how quickly we move in here fam where's
the
where's the what time frame is this
because you've banged four out of five
things
and then they've all comments let me
come to the same house play after you
bang four out of five and then they're
cussing you out
how have you not known that they're
bredrins yeah what's going on what's
going on what vicinity
first of all shout me because i'm trying
to fly there because
everyone's freaking up and no one's
asking questions no
nqas bruh no questions asked down there
and i need to know while go on
i need to know what one it's mad they're
do your research do your research first
man just because you're buff now
you it comes with responsibility it does
just do your research
it does come with yeah you need to
understand it like yet
i refuse to believe that of all of these
girls that was not one
picture with one other of these girls on
none of their pages
impossible it's impossible because you
didn't how else would you have contacted
them
you didn't randomly bump into it yeah
yeah
it's impossible in this day and age it's
impossible fam
it's impossible you found an instagram
or you found this
something yeah something something
something and you just have to do your
due diligence bro
i think that's the difference work smart
energy not harder work smarter work a
lot smarter
work the thing is the thing is if you
had done your due diligence
you may not have [ __ ] these other
girls and i'm not saying that's a good
or bad thing it is
it is where it is in itself but i am
proud of the confidence that you you've
gotten out of this change
yeah yeah yeah yeah just cleaning up
regardless of the circle
yeah that's the thing as well i think
also is about like yeah definitely
it's gotten to a point now where foo has
advice is long gone
like obviously you've done a thing but
like
you also have to take responsibility
for the moves that you're making in
terms of like you can't be like oh
i smashed this thing paid her off smash
this thing pile her off
and then when people are calling you a
[ __ ] boy
you're like yeah yeah yeah yeah i
shouldn't have taken first advice i
don't know if i should take him for his
advice it's not my fault
if you're gonna smash things and stop
talking to them people are gonna call
you a fuckboy
you just have to you have to roll with
it yeah that comes with it bro it comes
with a territory whether you think you
are or not which is fine we're not
judging like
that's absolutely fine and even if you
think you are that again is also fine
but just like that doesn't come through
to like oh man maybe this transformation
wasn't for me
it's like two completely different
things they're completely different
completely different too
do you do diligence don't smash the same
group of friends if you are gonna smash
the same group of friends hey bro if you
get approached in a party that's
something you just have to firm you have
to deal with you have to expect you
can't expect that
and it's just like cool just roll with
it again this at this point it has
nothing to do with flakes man said i
might ask her for taking a few hours
advice you know
when you read that my eyes wider than
the cuz what advice did i give
bro so yeah if you're going to be moving
in these streets you have to just like
either
move smart and if you're not going to
move smart because clearly you not
moving smart is still paying off for you
if you're not going to move smart and
you're just going to live life on the
edge
then you have to face the music when it
comes out you have to just face it with
your chest and move on
on move on that's it yeah if these are
the choices you're going to make in life
then you just have to
roll with it like you said like when
they were doing all these things they
didn't phase you good
move with it that's it but don't start
thinking this is now about to do with
the transformation
it has nothing to do with it you're just
moving recklessly
you've got gas this christmas for you it
is we've all been there bro
sometimes when you're juggling you think
you're invincible you think you're
bulletproof you're not because they will
drop you in a second oh fam oh
when you go from juggling [ __ ] to
having no [ __ ]
this is a true reflection it's a true
reflection sometimes i actually look at
myself in the mirror
i'm like damn i've got no one you know
that um that philly and chunks snippet
which one
where philly's looking at he's like is
there something wrong with you bro
it's just something is there something
wrong with me bro
that's how you feel when you're juggling
hoes and then you've got nothing nothing
you're literally looking at yourself
like is there something wrong with me
bruv
i've been in that situation in the past
i think every guy's been there i've
definitely been in there that's
that's how that's how i get
when um that's how i get this is how the
fans make me feel
like philly i feel like philly yeah at
times when i'm i'm high on life
yeah and then we'll get a string because
they always come in groups
no one ever there's never just one out
there yeah there's never just one out
there they always come in groups
so this last week or two we had
about three comments people paying off
my haircut cause i'm gonna get a haircut
and i was like
all right cool and then we had um
a couple years like who had sex appeared
it's just
a one something along those lines
something along those lines figure out
sexy blows up and i'm like cool it is
it is is and then we had another
dm that i came across and i sent it to
you
and it was like one guy just sharing a
story like oh you guys prepped me i lost
my virginity it was live
then he then he just took it another
level and was like
yo i smashed this thing out fab and it
was my first time i did not quick
james i don't know what was going on
with you fam and then he just slewed me
out for half a paragraph and then at the
very end was like pierce if you had your
beard's sick
and i'm like what's going on philly is
there something wrong with me bro
why is everyone sending for me whatever
i've done telling me and we can resolve
it
why is everyone standing for me and when
he's not even part of the topic
he has to get the little life of yeah
yeah you're sick
my guy my guy my hitter i'm just there
like cool bro that's too funny i guess
i'm just [ __ ] on the shoes
no i'm fine the fans love you i always
tell you the fans love you you make this
show bro you think it's a joke
oh fam that that was that week just gone
and
that was on our side there's something
wrong with me is there something wrong
with me
what have i done everyone's just sending
for man
um oh that's jokes but yeah um you're
not also for taking the advice obviously
because you're brand new
but yeah you're you're the [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] for blaming my boy
that you know that
that it's his fault that that you're
you're moving back you're just
you're you're an [ __ ] for moving mad
you're not asking for taking my advice
yes my advice helped you gain your
confidence which i'm happy for
um but like jimmy said con confidence
comes with consequence
so you gotta roll with your punches man
you gotta work smart
that's it 100 bro there's been times
perfect time there's been times
um in the past where you have been
juggling pum and they've been in the
same clique
and you've been responsible enough to be
like no as soon as you clock the same
click you've literally just
picked your lane and you're like i'm not
even gonna i'm not even gonna do this
it's not worth it it's actually it's not
worth it it's really because
you're going to lose both of them or all
of them or whatever it is and you just
because what hurt everyone's feelings
it's pointless they're going to hate you
afterwards it's pointless i hate being
hated
i hate being hated i thought it was the
only one
i can't stand being hated there's an
episode of recess back in the day
i love recess there's an episode of
recess
i love this episode there's only a few
episodes of recess that i truly remember
one where vince is the cook and he's
crushing it in the kitchen and where
mikey's the sings in the toilet mikey
sings in the toilet voice
gretchen's sick with yo-yos yes i
remember the episode
spinelli realizes her name's ashley she
has to become one of the actors
she goes to the clubhouse recess is so
gang
and then there's one where tj um gang
remembering all their names by the way
fam i don't know how i remember that i
don't know how you just reeled them off
like you've got a paper thumb it's this
room this room just signed to my mind
um there's one where tj finds out one
random kid doesn't like him
one random kid doesn't like it i think
he's younger than him yeah i remember
begging to find out why don't you like
me
remember everyone loves tj and he's i
don't like tj and then like he's begging
him why do you like me why do they like
me why didn't like he's i
it's fine you need to learn like yeah
that's fine okay
and he can't firm it that's me when so i
find that someone doesn't like me
ah bro i've been with girlfriends in the
past i've realized this as of actually
only in the last like year or two
that i realized like a lot of the reason
why
i've been with girlfriends and not
broken up with girlfriends or tried to
break up with them and ended up staying
with them
is because i just don't want them to not
like me as a person so i mean
when i can see that i'm breaking their
heart and all this stuff i end up being
like taking it all back
because i think they're not they they
think i'm a piece of [ __ ] i need i need
them to not think i'm an [ __ ] because
i'm not
and it's that's not in uh what's the
word i'm looking for in a
conceited type of way yeah it's just
more of a
i'm a nice guy man what does that mean
i'm a nice guy to be around people
i'm really nice i'm actually really
stupid i'm horrible to anyone ever in my
life
even if i don't like you i'm really
polite to everyone so when someone
actually thinks i'm a dick
i'm like no i'm not fam
please like me
um oh that's a joke but yeah um
obviously we live in melangee
move on from it it's all good and then
uh yeah let us know what happens next
time
yeah about see my later